Y
THREAT REALLY IS.
DON'T MISS IT.
FOLKS, THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT MONOLOGUES I HAVE EVER
DONE.
YOU KNOW THE OLD ADAGE HISTORY
DOESN'T REPEAT ITSELF BUT IT
RHYMES.
THINGS AREN'T BAD ENOUGH FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE TO WAKE UP FROM
THE KOOL-AID SLUMBER.
THAT'S WHY THE REPUBLICANS HAD A
DECENT DAY.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER DAY.
WE GOT AN OKAY DAY.
INFLATION IS AT RECORD HIGHS,
THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN.
THE FENTANYL CRISIS IS WIPING
OUT KIDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
CRIME IS SURGING AND THE ECONOMY
IS IN THE GUTTER.
BIG GOVERNMENT IS TRYING TO
SILENCE YOUR VOICE, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BAD STUFF
AIN'T ENOUGH.
IT WILL GET WORSE BEFORE SOME
VOTERS REALIZE.
I HAVE LIVED THROUGH THIS
BEFORE.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS HOW MUCH
WORSE IS IT GOING TO GET?
I GUESS THE ANSWER IS A LOT
WORSE AS LONG AS VOTERS KEEP
BELIEVING CRAP LIKE THIS.
>> WHAT IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS DO
YOU INTEND TO DO DIFFERENTLY.
>> NOTHING.
THE MORE THEY KNOW WHAT WE ARE
DOING THE MORE SUPPORT THERE IS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK CRIME
IS UP WHEN WE SEE SHOOTINGS ARE
DOWN.
SUBWAY CRIME IS UP, BUT IT'S UP
AFTER THEY COMMITTED SO MANY
MORE OFFICERS TO THE SUBWAY
SYSTEM.
ADDING MORE COPS TO THE SUBWAY
ISN'T GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
DAN: THINGS ARE GOING TO GET
BETTER.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
BEFORE IN DEEP BLUE STATES AND
CITIES WHERE I GREW UP.
THE ECONOMIST HERB STEIN SAID
WHAT CAN'T CONTINUE WON'T.
RAMPANT CRIME AND INFLATION
CAN'T CONTINUE.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
HOW WE ARE AT THE END OF A BAD
CYCLE.
I CAN SEE IT, I CAN FEEL IT, I
LIVED THROUGH IT.
TAKE RUDY GIULIANI'S RISE TO
POWER IN NEW YORK CITY.
I WAS THERE, I SAW IT, I LIVED
IT.
MANY CONSERVATIVES THOUGHT HE
WOULD NEVER BE MAYOR.
THE ODDS WERE TOO TIGHTLY
STACKED AGAINST HIM.
HE RAN, AND INITIALLY HE LOST
BECAUSE OF THE SAME THING THAT
HAPPENED TUESDAY.
THINGS JUST HADN'T GOTTEN BAD
ENOUGH TO WAKE PEOPLE UP.
CHECK OUT THIS HEADLINE FROM THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" IN 1990.
THE YEAR BEFORE MURDERS HIT
1,905 DEAD HUMAN BEINGS IN BODY
BAGS.
THEY WEREN'T BAD ENOUGH
APPARENTLY TO CHANGE.
IN THE 1989 NEW YORK CITY
MAYORAL ELECTION HE RAN ON A
TOUGH ON CRIME AGENDA AND HE
CAME THIS CLOSE TO UPSETTING THE
DEMOCRAT.
BUT BY TUESDAY THINGS JUST
WEREN'T BAD ENOUGH.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED FOUR YEARS
LATER FOR THOSE OF YOU READY TO
GIVE UP.
HOMICIDES GOT EVEN WORSE JUST
LIKE THEY WILL NOW.
THEY TOPPED 2,200 BODY BAGS IN
1990 AND 2,197 CORPSES IN 1993.
BUT THINK WERE CLUSTERS IN POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE RICH ELITES DIDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT WASN'T BAD ENOUGH FOR THEM
YET.
THEM WHEN EVERYBODY WAS READY TO
GIVE ON NEW YORK CITY, GIULIANI
PULLED OFF THE UNTHINKABLE IN
DEEP DEEP BLUE NEW YORK AND WON
BY A SLIVER IN THAT REMATCH.
THEN HE ACTED ON HIS PROMISES
CALLED CONSERVATIVE STUFF LIKE
LAW AND ORDER AND ECONOMIC
SANITY.
AND THE CRAZY THING HAPPENED.
THE CITY CLEANED UP.
IT WAS LIKE A MIRACLE EXCEPT IT
WASN'T.
IT WAS JUST COMMON SENSE
CONSERVATISM.
THEN FOUR YEARS LATER RUDY
GIULIANI RAN FOR REELECTION.
JUST KIDDING.
HE ACTUALLY WON BY 17 POINTS.
IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT JUST MAPPED
IN FLORIDA WITH RON DeSANTIS.
RESULTS MATTER.
BS IS CHEAP.
RESULTS WALK.
BS IS JUST TALK.
NOW DEMOCRATS BLAME DEMOCRATS
FOR THE PROBLEMS DEMOCRATS
CREATED.
VOTERS IN THE RED STATES ALREADY
FIGURED THAT OUT.
>> WE SAW FREEDOM AND OUR VERY
WAY OF LIFE IN SO MANY OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY
WITHER ON THE VINE.
FLORIDA HELD THE LINE.
>> NO AMOUNT OF MONEY WOULD
CONVINCE PEOPLE TO ACCEPT
MARXISM AND SOCIALISM.
>> FIGHT FOR THE PEOPLE, THE
SINGLE MOMS STRUGGLING TO RAISE
BABIES.
DAN: BUT IN SOME DISTRICTS IN
SOME BLUE STATES THEY HAVEN'T
FIGURED IT OUT YET.
BUT AS THE GOP LIKELY EMBRACES
ITS NEWLY GAINED POWER.
THERE IS A LESSON THAT CAN COME
FROM ALL OF THIS.
YOU BETTER DAMN WELL DELIVER.
REMEMBER, BS IS CHEAP TALK.
REMEMBER THE LOFTY PROMISES
DEMOCRATS MADE TO VOTERS?
>> RIGHT NOW WHO WE ARE AS A
NATION IS THAT WE HAVE A CROOKED
PATH AND IT'S TIME TO MAKE THAT
CROOKED PATH STRAIGHT.
>> OUR FOCUS WE DECIDE ON EARLY
ON, ON HEALTHCARE, WHO VERY,
VERY, VERY BENEFICIAL TO US
BECAUSE THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE FACING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS WILL
BE LED WITH TRANSPARENCY AND
OPENNESS.
RAISE WORKERS WAGES WITH STRONG
ECONOMIC GROWTH BY REBUILDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF AMERICA.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT
RESULTS.
DAN: GIULIANI AND DeSANTIS
DELIVERED.
BUT DID THOSE DEMOCRAT PROMISES
SOUNDS LIKE ANYTHING WE HAVE
TODAY?
I DON'T REMEMBER HEM PROMISES
HIGH INFLATION AND BODY BAGS AND
FENTANYL.
IF CONSERVATIVE LEADERS AREN'T
CAREFUL WE COULD FALL INTO A
SIMILAR TRAP WITH OUR NEWFOUND
POWER.
THE STUMP SPEECHES ARE OVER.
THE ONE LINERS DON'T CUT IT
ANYMORE.
THIS ISN'T A TIME FOR FOCUS
GROUPS.
IT'S TIME FOR ACTION.
WE ARE GIVING REPUBLICANS
ANOTHER CHANCE TO STOP THE
INSANITY AND REFORM.
IF CONSERVATIVES IN CONGRESS
DON'T REFORM THIS, NONE OF THAT
STUFF MATTERS.
IT'S TIME TO PUT THE MONEY WHERE
YOUR MOUTHS ARE.
IT'S TIME FOR YOU